today on stick to football Conor and I
coming to you from the BR London offices
this place is is a lot of fun actually I
love this office it's awesome it's very
old school bleacher report they were
nice enough out here to share the space
with us and to be our football ranks
guys this is their home base and as r8c
switch it out with something a little
different yeah we're gonna actually burn
the studio to the ground lengths on so
that's just the nice of hashtag America
but we've had a lot of fun here it is
time to get back talking about our good
ol American football though a good show
today we're gonna go around the league
we're do some stock watch as far as the
NFL Draft goes a top ten mock draft and
then some draft on [ __ ] so if you've
been one of those peoples like hey we
wish you guys would get back to the
draft today is a lot of that for you and
a reminder because we're coming up on it
two weeks away basically
November 9th will be at Alabama LSU
which thank you LSU for bidding Auburn
thank you for Alabama beating Arkansas
because we still have the top two teams
in the country now LSU is number one
this game is gonna be wild and we want
you guys come tailgate with us on the
quad November 9th as early as they let
us in there I think it'll be around 7
a.m. up until kickoff yeah I mean look
it was a couple scares in that LSU game
where we're like come on whatever this
happens right now but yes we lucked out
here and once again we're expecting a
surprise guest to join us on the quad
that I think a lot of people will his
CEO bleacher report texted me and he was
like who's the surprise guest I gotta
tell you no don't don't tell me I told
him cuz he could fire me that's fair he
knows I was gonna leak now yeah I was
gonna tell everyone now when it gets out
I know why the surprise is ruined
right but for real it's I think people
are gonna have a blast we're gonna have
food Matt Miller driving god bless them
so we'll have every all the equipment
we'll even have the tablecloth that we
almost forgot in the pub last night
Thank You Adam all the koozies there's a
team effort over here at bleacher poor
that's how we work makes the dream work
but we got to talk about some football
your Matt some American football we do
buddy and two of my teams remain
undefeated with some inside know how to
pick up your third one put up a hell of
a fight they really did without their
MVP quarterback who apparently has
robotic nice but the Niners of Patriots
stay undefeated both doing it on the
strengths of their defense the Patriots
didn't look great against the Cleveland
Browns but their defense was able to
just completely
like confirm a field I mean Baker's
pitching the ball the defensive lineman
is it was not a good look for the Browns
who they continue to just fall apart
offensively week after week they really
do and it's a shame because you look at
a guy like Nick Chubb who you know I
think it's one of the better running
backs in football right now - it was so
uncharacteristic almost of him to fumble
the way he was and like you said the
turnovers from Baker and this is a
hungry New England defense those guys up
front I know we've given a lot of love
to the secondary whether it's McCourty
you know whether it's obviously the best
corner rack and football and Gilmore
well you look at these linebackers and
how they're getting it done whether it's
van Noy who's resurrected is still
amazing I mean from an underappreciated
developed player at one time he goes to
New England and becomes what looks like
an all-pro caliber player they have
Hightower there Jamie Collins is it's
just hilarious when you look at how New
England does it and that's why coaching
matters and I think when it comes down
to it right now New England's just
showing wha
you know the Browns got a lot of hype
this summer and I get it and everyone's
guilty of that but no England's showing
why they've been you know the kings of
the castle here for quite some time for
20 years like they're still good for 20
years I mean I was a little kid when
this started that's right I was in high
school that's how long ago this was it's
ridiculous when you think of it like
that yeah I know my my daughter has
never lived in a world where the
Patriots are bad she's a freshman in
college there you go I'm quite over it
to be completely transparent but I've
also just grown to accept it right yeah
and the Niners I think they're listen
they're not taking the Patriots model
per se but it is they were the strong
defense the good run game
play-action passing I hope as a fan and
as an analyst I hope we see the Niners
passing game wake up now that Emanuel
Sanders is there hopefully that'll get
people like George kiddo more targets we
saw Sanders get a touchdown in his first
game we saw Tevin Coleman really have a
big impact coming out of the backfield
so maybe more balanced offensively is
really what the Niners needed they also
they have get healthy up front it's just
gonna search daily will come back Mike
McGlinchey will come back and I hope and
pray that this really we see the passing
game open up because it has been a
little cautious so far this year yeah I
think for the Niners like you just
pointed out to Matt they're a team
waiting to get all the way healthy I
think coaching when you could tell if
there's great coach
when they can make adjustments without
starting players and I think not just
Kyle Shanahan but even the defensive
staff in San Francisco has really done a
marvelous job and you know another thing
we talked about on the Monday show that
came out late in case you missed it it's
not Nick Bose it just looks like
possibly you know one of the best
defensive players in all football right
now not rookie one of the best defensive
players in all football absolutely does
and and I will say we are recording this
Monday I have to think about what day it
was Monday so we're recording this
before the trade deadline is over the
show comes out Wednesday so we apologize
but that's the way the schedule works
but I do want to talk about the trade
deadline because Kenya Drake was traded
to the Cardinals for a conditional 2020
pick as we were recording here on Monday
can you drink to the Cardinals there's
some other trades that I'm actually
getting some text about as we're
recording and we'll jump into that but
my initial reaction to you when the
Drake trade came through was this
doesn't make sense why a team that is
three four and one with the Seahawks
Niners and Rams ahead of them in their
division but also Kenya Drake is a free
agent after this year so that one thing
I said you maybe they believe they can
get a higher compensatory selection if
he leaves a free agency but this is a
weird move to me for a team that they
believe they still have some ability to
make a push here down the run and I
think also maybe they're just looking
for a complementary piece for Kyler
Murray right now while they continue to
develop him under this Kliff Kingsbury
offense and I think you know you can't
really undervalued that if they feel and
I like Kenyan Drake as a pass catching
kind of back a back in space that has
explosive playability
I think the relationship what cliff will
be better than what he's had in the NFL
I know you know my favorite coach Adam
GaSe soured on him quite quickly while
in Miami I can't speak to what the new
staff in miami feels about him but
considering how willing they were to not
really play him and trade him it kind of
tells you everything you need to know
does I think you know David Johnson's
been hurt on and off again I think the
Cardinals don't have an offensive line I
think clip is is doing everything you
can think he's done a pretty damn good
job of it
and I think I they want to see what they
have in Kenyan Drake and Drake might you
know feel like hey if this is a place
that wants me and knows how to utilize
me maybe I saw in an in season extension
here rather than hit free agency roll
the dice on going
where else where I get buried under the
depth char and once again I do think he
could be more than just a running back
some other trade deadline rumors that
are out there right now and again by
Wednesday this could have all fallen
apart but I feel like it's still kind of
fun to tell you at least what we're
hearing before it happens I know we've
said last week even we didn't expect the
Chiefs to make a move I am now thinking
that they tried to get something done at
the cornerback position darius slay is
available Akita leaves available Troy
Wayans might be available so I think the
Chiefs now knowing they're gonna get my
homes back maybe this coming week
against the Titans or excuse me against
the Vikings if not the week following
and gets the Titans I think they realize
like okay we're still in this thing the
seasons not gonna fall apart they might
try to make a move it sounds like the
Falcons might be sellers I mean we can
see Shane Quinn fired so I wouldn't be
surprised if we see the Falcons move off
some guys yeah I'm with you there I
think when you look at it let's start
with it going back to the chief's point
we've seen Brett beech be a pedal to the
metal kind of guy and now that but
mahomes was expected to come back really
ahead off to Andy Reed for making Matt
Moore give the Packers everything that
Chiefs team had that would be I would be
applauded that I would be excited to see
them get some secondary help and not
paid the premium price the Rams did for
Jalen Ramsey I'm with you I think the
Falcons do need to move some players and
maybe think about blowing this thing up
soon when we talked about this on the
Friday show last week Robbie Anderson is
on the trade block Leonard Williams is
on the trade block I've Oakland Raiders
have been tied to them
I know Green Bay is looking for a wide
receiver I know Joe Douglas would want
day two selections for both of those
guys right and I don't even think you
could sit there and say hey we're a good
team that I'll give us our third if
you're a good team that's making the
playoffs the Jets are gonna want a
second-round pick because it'll be still
later in the round you're talking about
pick 55 to 64 kind of range so it'll be
curious to see how the Jets hold out
with those two guys there and honestly
this list goes on and on I think it's
it's more fun now that remember when me
and Matt started this show back in 2017
the trade deadline was this thing where
me and him would joke on the show go
back to it and back yeah we have to talk
about this because it's really required
this week but nothing ever happens fast
forward a couple years it's almost
turned into this NBA MLB style traded
for us it's great
G
are being aggressive they were utilizing
not just their draft picks for ready now
players but also knowing how to attack
caps facing compensatory picks and I
think it's a lot of fun so get ready for
a fun Friday show where we recap the
rest of those moves with Melo joining
it's gonna be great I do want to talk
about your guy before we get to our
second segment Sami Darnell who was my
number one quarterback in that class he
was Melos number one quarterback in that
class he has thrown seven interceptions
in seven days a great Bob I know there
are a lot of reasons and I'm not trying
to turn this into a Jets podcast there's
a lot of reasons the offensive line is
[ __ ] that we're seeing them that
obviously I don't like the receiver
group because they're breaking it apart
but my level of concern for Sam Darnell
there's someone who wants him to succeed
is pretty high right now it should be
here's the thing with Sam's Arnold all
of the things that Jeremy Bates improved
last year which does not get talked
about enough
never fumbled with Jeremy Baker right
he's a fumbling machine in college now
he's a fumbling machine again and I know
a lot of quarterbacks especially young
ones are having this problem we seen him
with Josh Allen we've seen it with
Daniel Jones like crazy this year it
happens but it's correctable but he's
throwing off his back foot he's just
throwing into coverage and it's
frustrating because you look at the
numbers and it's like well he's
completing a ton of passes against a
good Jacksonville defense but three
really bad decisions where you could
argue Robbie Anderson didn't do him
favor any favors on one of them are
eating Sam Donald up right now and that
was always the you know the narrative at
USC is hey man if he cuts back on some
of these all world's potential right and
you watch the Cowboys game a bad
interception that one but he killed it
the rest of that game he'd go back to
New England Jacksonville I they're
losing for a lot of reasons but Sam
Darnell does not get a pass on why
they're also losing yeah and this
transitions to a guy who also turned the
ball over a lot in college that we
worried about and he's continued to do
it in the NFL and that's Jameis Winston
and so I think if you're a Sam Donald
fan it's okay
hope to god he doesn't become that all
in the field that all filled us there's
no comparison no you hope he becomes
deshaun Watson who was able to overcome
a lot of turnovers his last year in
college and I think even early in his
career he still turned the ball over a
little bit too much but with Jameis
Winston just blank answer on this
buy or sell Jamis as the Bucks
quarterback next year
oh I'm selling I couldn't sell more I'll
sell everything I own
listen I know Bruce Arians is saying all
the right things
and Bruce Arians did the right thing by
taking this job tying himself to a GM
that really needed some saving at the
time and said hey I'll give it a shot
for a year and see what we have and
Bruce is still saying the right things
this team is drafting a quarterback come
on and the big caveat is who's gonna
fall to them are they got there's so
many bad team there are teams many teams
worse than the Bucks where they might
have to be aggressive and trade up for
someone but if you know Bruce right
Jacob Eason Jordan love like those guys
are probably gonna trickle down Bruce
loves those big arm players even Justin
Herbert Justin Herbert if he falls that
far I still and I know you've said this
a lot Matt we're not super high on
Justin Herbert I still think the league
will be very high in just somebody not
every gonna happen yeah it's got
everybody so the Bucks and I should give
you some time are you buying or selling
well I'm selling I'm absolutely
I was out like after his rookie year
yeah I'm selling and I was at the same
about Mariota obviously you know who's
been benched to Tennessee yeah I would
sell the Bucs right now hold at night to
picking the draft so they're drafted
early enough we're gonna quarterback you
get a quarterback there we're gonna
we're gonna do it about that right do it
soon we'll see if they get their
quarterback let's take a break we come
back we'll give you some stock watch
around the college football excuse me
the NFL Draft season from last week in
college football all right Connor it's
time to play a little stock watch and
you can't talk about someone whose stock
is going up without mentioning chase
young the defensive end from Ohio State
you guys are gonna get tired of hearing
about him he's that good though and he
did it again four sacks on Saturday
against Wisconsin double-digit on the
year he has a chance to break the single
season record at Ohio State he has a
chance to break the career record at
Ohio State he should be the number one
player in the draft period like I always
say it's an ink it's done if this show
had a Heisman vote that would be it and
it's [ __ ] we don't but we still are
frustrated that we don't chase young is
your Heisman Trophy winner right now and
Matt I can't just agree with you there I
mean look at what he does every week and
you're always kind of some people go
I remember the first chase young clip I
tweeted out this year and then like the
second one the next week and people were
like well yeah look who he's playing how
about now what about now what for right
for sex against Wisconsin or is it three
I mean yeah it doesn't matter right he's
he's beating top competition you just
look at what chase young does and it's
been phenomenal he's the best player in
this craft I'm gonna go on the defensive
side of the ball as well Matt I'm sorry
to do this to you don't you have to
don't get me wrong he gave up a couple
catches let's not act like he was
perfect Jeff Gladney from TCU
when we did our fixing the Jets mock
drafts and Matt had him going to the
Jets I believe in the second round this
is why Jeff gladden good is a feisty
sticky corner in the big 12 for TCU and
he did it against a guy like Colin
Johnson who has quite a few inches on
every corner he comes across
I love Gladney I know you've been a big
fan of Gladney and Jeff Okuda is amazing
you know Christian Fulton has had a
really nice year LSU there's eligible
corners in this class that are very good
but Jeff Gladney needs to be in this
conversation going forward as a guy that
can impact your team next top 40 for me
there you go top 40 and not to Pat
myself on the back or anything like that
because that's not what we do here we
try to make fun of our misses but his
rise reminds me a lot of where we were
with rocky sinned last year where I
think we were early on him and tried to
educate people like hey this employers
gonna go top 40 handed up 34 overall so
I think I think Gladney has a chance to
rise in that level I mean he's in my top
40 so he's already there stock down for
me this one hurts because this one her
excuse me because we love him but
Jonathan Taylor the question has been
can he get it done against a great team
52 yards against Ohio State and I know
they fell behind and they they had to
throw the ball a little bit but he was
bottled up he looked frustrated it's
honestly the worst game I can remember
seeing him play yeah I think what's
frustrating what Taylor is you look at
some of the backstrap did early in
recent years and not all of them there's
been tough plenty of power kind of guys
and I think Taylor is more athletic than
people give him credit for I agree yeah
but he's not McCaffrey camara say Quan
or even DeAndre swift in open space he's
just not that
kind of guy and he's a good he's
probably a great player but I think this
is a game where you look at it and you
go hey can he take over even against a
defense with elite athletes and he just
didn't that's what's frustrating running
back that I do have stock up who has had
his own fair share questions this year
but Clemson is leaning back on Travis
etn the last three weeks he's gone over
a hundred yards after a stretch of not
even coming close to a hundred yards
it's almost like they saw all the
questions about their young quarterback
and said hey when this kid came in and
took over for Kelly Bryant we were a lot
we leaned on Travis etn he's struggling
now and obviously the young quarterback
in Trevor Lawrence let's lean back on
Travis etn these three games he's been
phenomenal I mean two weeks ago he
averages over 13 yards of carry and this
week he gets in the end zone three times
against Boston College it's good to see
etn as a pure runner do the kind of
damage he did last year
these last three we've been waiting for
it we it took awhile let's be fair yeah
it's gonna happen and even earlier in
the year when we would talk about what's
going on with Trevor Lawrence how do you
fix it we kept saying go back to him
well he's a young quarterback exactly go
back to - Travis etn and yeah they
whipped Boston College maybe 9 to 7 it's
a maze not pretty not sure shout-out to
Ally from the college chaps podcast we
met here who's a die-hard Boston College
fan in London yeah we're in a Jersey
Boston College Jersey
yes fashion here is not left at the
Dorset right all right last stock up for
me and it's two players who actually
were in this same game ylvis' Cascino
wide receiver Colorado and Michael
Pittman junior wide receiver USC
Chennault went 9 for 172 Pittman went 7
for 156 USC won this game but both
players and I know we've like talking
about she's not like where does he play
and then he goes off right it's like
where does he play I still haven't been
the first round but it's gonna be skiing
specific I would love to see him in an
offense like Philadelphia where they
would utilize him get him a lot of
designated touches where you're not just
a wide receiver you're someone who is is
gonna have some schemed touches some you
know find ways to get you the ball
whether it's jet sweeps put you in the
backfield you know quick screens I
should also phenomenal player Michael
Pittman is just physical as hell I got
someone in the pub asked me like who
does Michael Pittman remind you of and I
was like DK Metcalf
without the hype like he's just so
physically so big and he's probably not
gonna run a fourth yeah that's ek so
he's probably gonna run a three cone
that's not in the seven second range so
there's that I mean he's a big dude
it's ridiculous hwacha wide reciever
acht up he's like he's kind of built
like Evan Engram was but he really plays
wide receiver they don't like play him
as this fake tight end so I think when
you look at him that size is great and I
think he's someone that should go to the
Senior Bowl and get in those one-on-ones
and bully some cornerback so I like
those picks there and back to Chanel
it's good to see him we were screaming
get this guy involved where is the
involvement why am i going on to watch
Colorado every week when we land back in
the tailgate tour and I see in the sheet
that she not had four targets two
catches 22 yards right
tired of it and you know what it's good
to see them go against a tough USC team
that does have some talent on the
defense and and he was the guy yeah it's
Kris a funny thing that happens when
you're in the UK I've never been here
before
I googled Michael Pittman jr. cuz like
how much do they list him at well he's
listed at 1.9 3 meters and 99 kilograms
over here I don't know what that means
but I'll tell you that he's probably 6 1
to 30 yeah
I have to Google and translator to
figure that all right let's take a break
we come back we're gonna rip through a
top ten mock draft with the updated
order it is Monday when we're recording
not when you're listening so we're gonna
do a mock draft Monday for you that
comes out on Wednesday I know that was
confusing but it was on purpose so
number one overall this has not changed
the Cincinnati Bengals are still
projected to have the first pick in the
draft and I really did think about
should I give them chase young should I
give them jobber oh I'm going to give
them to a tango viola we're trying to
keep this realistic what we think will
happen what we're hearing will happen as
of now - it would still be the first
pick and that's why what's often somehow
picking it - and if they beat the Jets
next weekend they're only gonna fall
back but I have the Dolphins taking
jobber oh and I thought really hard
about this would chase young I really
did Matt and it goes back to something
we always say and this is us trying to
predict what's gonna happen that's not
what we're gonna do when teams
believe a guy could be a good NFL
quarterback they take him the Giants
last year proved this theory as right as
it could ever be where nobody was taking
Daniel Jones
I don't think in the top 14 picks or
whatever it was where the Giants could
have rolled the dice and packaged their
second first around her to come back up
for him after taking a pass rusher at
six but they didn't do that because they
had the belief that Daniel Jones will be
a good quarterback and it doesn't matter
where we take him I could see the
Dolphins falling into the same kind of
idea what she'll burrow at second
overall and when you back yourself into
a corner remember they did this with
Ryan Tannehill they backed themselves
into a corner not saying jobber will be
Ryan Tannehill but they've done this in
the past number three right now will be
the Washington Redskins you have to
believe that Dewayne Haskins will get a
chance next year i know adrian peterson
had some comments earlier this week
about how he thought Haskins needed to
study more we'll see what happens there
I'm not ready to say it's over with
Dewayne Haskins but I think you have to
at least wonder a little bit like okay
what's going on behind closed doors
there for the time being
chase young number one player on my
board that's not for the time being
that's forever I think they have to go
pass rusher here even after getting
Montez sweat last year ranked arrogance
getting older this is still a big need
for them at Chase young is clearly the
best player on the board yeah you're not
gonna get any kind of argument from me
there my biggest question is who's gonna
be making this draft pick yeah and will
they come in and take the job and say
I'm only taking the job if you let me
pick my quarterback
and then it goes as haskins gonna get
Rosen's right I'm just saying or Jimmy
Clausen yeah that was well I don't even
want to get into Jimmy Clausen right
alright number four I don't know how
this team is here the Atlanta Falcons
are somehow picking fourth and they need
a lot of help I don't think anything's
changing with Matt Ryan as their
quarterback and that's fine so I'm gonna
go with Jeff Okuda here at four and now
people are gonna raise an eyebrow
cornerback at fourth overall he's that
good matt has brought up that he could
be his highest rated cornerback we've
seen in quite some time and I think when
you look at Atlanta they're gonna be
very best player available approach here
where if chase young is gone
they might look in the other direction
on defense and they've invested a lot at
wide receiver in recent years where I
don't think this would be a Jerry Judy
spot that's what I think too like then
like Calvin Ridley yes well obviously
Julio as long as he's there said at wide
receiver I
put a CUDA to them a lot in my mock
draft well it just makes a lot of sense
but again we don't know who's gonna be
making this pick we don't know who's
gonna be coaching this team and there
could be major shakeups in Atlanta over
the offseason that I wouldn't rule out
any position at this point oh because
they just obviously have needs
everywhere
number five of the New York Giants this
is not the best player available for me
that would be Jerry Judy but I don't see
them drafting a receiver this early I
went with Andrew Thomas Jeff had some
tackle from Georgia nay solders on the
trade block he may have been traded by
the time we're talking you guys are
listening to the show excuse me
I think Adrian Thomas I still have
questions about his ability to hold up
against speed on the outside but he's so
physical he's technically very very
sound I think he's gonna be a good left
hackle in the NFL and the Giants badly
need that right they really do Daniel
Jones is taking quite the beating early
on here he's taking some really big
shots early in his career as a lot of
these young quarterbacks have because
they don't have the offensive line
figured out I mean we saw it at a time
with Carson Wentz we saw it at a time
with Jared Goff then deshaun Watson the
list goes on and on so I love that pick
for the Giants and it puts me in a tough
spot at 6 for the Jets because people
are screaming this is an awful offensive
line
I agree but there's no one I'm taking
here over Jerry Judy I think if you go
into this direction Joe Douglas has to
go into the offseason like this they
have a lot of money to spend he needs to
buy an offensive line exactly and you
need to go into the draft with
flexibility where you're probably gonna
use some of your mid round picks
hopefully more after the trade deadline
on offensive line but if Andrew Thomas
is not there when you pick in the first
round and Jerry Judy is it's easy money
when was the last number one wide
receiver at the Jets at oh my god
Brandon Marshall was for one year
Keyshawn one year he's Wayne Chrebet
count it's just and they you had like
flashes of Santonio Holmes and brown ed
right that was duo you need a go-to
target a normal young quarterback maybe
the last one yeah I mean they traded his
ass real quick which is yeah I was a
young angry right exactly
no I agree with you and I would pick
Judy here as well I know Jets fans back
we need offensive line help you do but
as you said you're gonna have to buy
that read it yeah because I I don't know
that there's a left tackle to take at
number six overall number seven is the
Denver Broncos I believe that they will
give drew Locke a chance next year to be
the quarter
back in this team so I have them go in
defensive line Derrick wolf appear 4-h
and I believe a JEP Anessa
has not had the big statistical season
that I think a lot of us expected but
he's still really really good at
football he's still very high draft pick
a draft prospect
I think epinasty it's this team
perfectly Vic Fangio had a lot of
success with guys like Justin Smith oh
yeah Teddy Goldman and Hakeem Hicks
looking amazing in Chicago I think
epinet fit for Vic Fangio Steve fence as
long as he's still the head coach there
yeah I still believe in epinet
I know people get frustrated with the
lack of stats in production but I think
he's got traits for days is what I would
say number eight is the Arizona
Cardinals now unlike the Jets where I
couldn't take this guy over Jerry Judi
Jerry Judy's off the board now pay for
Arizona much like the Jets they need
offensive line help and that's why we're
gonna go Tris than worse here I think
they need a tackle somebody that is
played right tackle Matt as you know
said many times on the show that there's
a belief he can play on the left side if
needed
the Cardinals are another one of these
teams that just needs to keep stacking
the deck with offensive lineman and
whoops would be the next guy up yeah I
think with me I agree they need
offensive line help badly and I love
trust no worse I don't know if we'll see
I don't know if Kingsburg is gonna value
offensive line I don't know either I
hope so
a hell of a Strad but I really don't I
really don't know what his plan is gonna
be there so there's gonna be interesting
to watch at 9:00 the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers I really wanted to go Grant
Delpit here because they've missed out
on safeties in the past had to go
quarterback though Justin Herbert goes
here for me
I think we've we've tried to be really
transparent about our individual beliefs
about the quarterback class
I think Justin Herbert has all the tools
in the world he's gonna look really
really pretty throwing the football he's
got a big Army's good athlete everybody
says he's a good kid I the only
questions have been about like toughness
football toughness his head coach Mario
Cristobal has shot that down and said
he's incredibly tough he's not worried
about that I think you're Herbert fits
what Bruce Arians once yeah they can
move and some of they could throw the
ball down the field and that's gonna be
the big question Bruce Arians might love
the way the picture is painted but I
don't know if he'll really sit down with
him and be like hey this is my kind of
my kind of guy
I don't know we'll see so quarterback
asking me it has to be on the on the
radar for Tampa right now and I think it
will be
when all is said and done alright number
ten here Manan finished think this thing
out with a very unconventional pick and
that's all gonna come down to medical
Trey Smith from Tennessee was a
five-star recruit that came in as a
freshman and was a phenomenal football
player then the blood clot situation
happened that took him off the field for
a very long time he's been back this
year he's not playing tackle he's
playing guard
I saw him kick the [ __ ] out of a couple
players on Alabama right if you can do
that you are probably going to be a very
good NFL player now this is comes with
the caveat here that if Trey Smith has
some medical problems arise at the
combine he's simply not gonna go in the
first round no matter how good he is but
on tape and this has been the way since
he was in high school he is a
first-round caliber offensive lineman
and the Dolphins desperately need one of
those and this would be this is the
earliest you'll see Trey Smith anywhere
right now but I am fully a believer in
this guy's talent I make sure to see
like said the medical someone should see
does he come out yes he tried to stay
and get more tape because yeah this was
a five-star kid who was looked at very
very good as a true freshman playing
left tackle and then yeah we see him
missed mostly the 2018 season with the
blood clots so yeah it's gonna scream
interesting to watch but the talent is
absolutely there depending on when he
decides to come out all right that's our
mock draft tweet us a stick to football
leave it in your items or you let us
know what you think and also let us know
when you want a full round one mock
because I'm itching to get one of those
TT but we'll be around to range by
December this you can't wait let's do it
we got a couple draft on draft questions
to close out the show this week the
first door from our guy Jake rubbish
check knowing how much you guys love my
homes how would the NFL be different
today if the bills hadn't traded down
with the Chiefs in the 2017 draft and
they just took my homes for themselves
instead the bills might be the favorite
to win the AFC they still had shaman so
we need some Shawn yes I said coach and
table you wouldn't have today vyas white
who's really good that's fair but I mean
yeah I think there would be it they're
definitely a playoff team and they would
be the favorite they would probably be
the favorite when they have seat at
least it would be they'd be in this
conversation with New England well you
take away Kansas City right that seems
crazy so I still think that the bills
like they would have bought their
offensive line
they would I had to really attack the
wide receiver groups differently because
that's one thing and even talking to
people Buffalo they're like yeah we need
receivers but we had to buy it we had to
build an offensive line
so like the receivers come next with hat
I think he would have needed those
weapons a little bit earlier I think so
too I mean we love Pat and Pat is the
best quarterback in football but it's
when you watch it's amazing how seamless
the fit is and Andy Reid's offense with
Tyree kill me call Hardman now right I
mean and then even the complementary
pieces like last year instead of
drafting at Oliver they might have had
to draft a receiver you know or TJ
Hawkins Marquis Brown
yeah or instead of Tremayne Edmonds the
year before they might have had to you
know go after a more of a premier wide
receiver but it's fun to think about it
is what would how different it would be
and also and this is some of the Pat has
said before to us you know that you're
getting to sit behind Alex Smith helped
him so much if he had been trapped in a
buffalo he would have forced in I don't
know if he would be where he is right
now and then you would have got there
but I don't really I mean he's on throw
50 touchdowns a second years you know in
the NFL or started right but it's fun to
think about this and I look good that
uniform revisionists revisionists is the
best way to do it like what if the dread
the Jets took the Shaun Watson the
quarterbacks more Ava what if the Browns
might it would be no difference if they
took Sam zarnold first if they're taking
car turning the ball over that one's
interesting yeah I still don't know what
whence or Ghaffar which is unbelievable
this Florida and no idea I know you and
Lefko had the bet who's gonna be better
golfer wins and I think golf's better
than wins I don't even know how to
answer it anymore that's that's I mean
the best abilities availability yeah
winces hurt his locker room doesn't like
him I that's another story I can't
figure out I'm just getting into
conspiracy theories now it's fun Justin
bod spelled who in the 2020 draft class
is your dream combination with coach and
player his Colorado's the viscous
Channel and the Pittsburgh Steelers wow
that's not one question but I like it I
just want to make it clear oh I don't
want to make one too obvious right
CD lamb on the 49ers oh god that would
be amazing dream
I was gonna not take it like the Niners
cuz that's why I did it for you yeah
that's a really good one this is so much
harder my knees jobber oh and the Titan
I was just gonna say that's the one I
keep bragging like please God let this
happen I don't know if it actually will
or not easton on the bucks it makes a
lettuce it's like his new carson palmer
exactly they are a lot of like i know i
did it in the mock trap but I think
epinet fits Denver really really well as
long again as long as Fangio is there
you know they went like really tough
last year with Dalton rise in error and
yeah I'm trying to build up the
offensive and defensive lines think
those are good fits yeah this is that's
a fun game to play if I could be like
complete Homer this would never happen
but Henry rugs in Kansas City of course
they would have four three guys running
sub for three basically oh it'd be
absolutely ridiculous you wouldn't be
able to stop them no the drugs
fascinates me this I got thinking about
this the other day when it came out and
I believe it was Vic taper just to give
proper credit that said Oakland was
interested in Robbie Anderson and I sit
there and I go I hate that landing spot
for Robbie Rosen and it makes you go
what if like somebody with a very
underwhelming vertical attack drafts
Henry rugs like when the Bengals took
John Ross right and I want to make this
very clear
Henry rugs is a better prospect all
around much better I want to make that
very clear but the point is the fit
matters so much for someone like rugs
where listen if will fuller is gonna get
hurt every single year a good axons
don't have any pics right well like
that's a team that could throw them all
down the field right the Saints and
Henry rugs and they need a number two
god damn that would be great
they really need a number I would yeah
you he'd catch me rooting for the Saints
a lot if they're that would be fun and
Mike Thomas [ __ ]
one more Kenneth Murray to the Ravens
great fit yeah and they love those
Oklahoma boys where would you want to
see chase Young go if you can go
anywhere
I mean but like where would you really
want to see him go not Miami that's the
point
yeah get away from the Bengals Jets
right my bad teams the Giants I'd like
to see him go to the Giants he and steak
want on the same team it'd be awesome
sure super
we're not friends I don't want to see
him on Seattle oh yeah trying to be
somewhat real that's why we do this show
we take things completely out of control
so if I could put him anywhere it be San
Francisco op and then D Ford plays like
four snaps a game it has three sacks
there you know what like you're gonna
hate but he would flourish in New
England oh it would kill it like these
disciplines but right get after the
quarterback yeah good thing is that's
not happening no they would have to
trade their entire draft and the draft
after great watch him go to Cleveland
just because God hates me he and miles
Garrett Garrett that Baker would still
throw picks to be fine all right last
question from a Monsey ideal first-round
for the Los Vegas
Raiders I keep forgetting they move
after this year they watch it IV I flew
over the stadium it's not it's not it
will be nice it wasn't this was a while
ago it was almost ready the location
looks great though yeah it's close it's
good very excited as of now they would
actually own picks 12 and 13 in the
first round
yeah so I because of all the work that
we have to do I think the wide receiver
is something they have to address so I
have to at 12 I would say CD lamb yep
it's where I would want them to go but I
actually like Derek cars deep ball
ability a little bit more than you might
so I would be okay with Henry rugs but
CD land would be my ideal fit and then I
would take Kenneth Murray one pick after
that okay hit that Oklahoma well I think
they need middle linebacker help I mean
obviously Vaughn says perfect is gone
they've really struggled to defend the
middle of the field Karl Joseph's a free
agent really their only notable one so
they they have needs in the middle that
field defensively so that would be not
the sexiest draft I think they need a
pass rusher but I don't know if anyone's
gonna be there so I would go receive her
in line back I think wide receiver will
be huge for them man here's the point
there Antonio Brown
yeah and he's gone and now like oh well
this is different if they're interested
in a deep threat like Robbie Anderson
that means they're interested in a deep
threat overall yeah wait and like you
said they've tried they haven't not
tried right so here's the question for
you though if Isaiah Simmons falls oh
that's beautiful
that's the fit that's the perfect fit I
know we're gonna you know this show
especially will be high on him but
like that fall it's just my James fill
the 17 guys guys just naturally fall a
little bit because of positional value
so I think that would be a really
interesting got if you get Simmons at 12
and CD Lam at 13
that's an amazing year for the Raiders
or Simmons at 12 rugs at 13 like that's
a good fit
one player I could definitely see being
a Raider is Derek Brown
oh yeah yeah not the biggest need for
them I don't know he he fits what Mayock
once that's it I mean look at what they
did last year yeah they took Cleveland
Farrell about 10 spots higher than
anyone expected him to go maybe 20 maybe
it but you know I know Abram got hurt
right but they have a type of player
Josh Jacobs has been very good and feels
like he's playing through quite the
shoulder injury and really gutting
things out but he's been very good so
when it comes down to it I mean Oakland
is a team that has it they're gonna be
easier for us to cross players off the
board for this I think so they just
won't take character players in the
first round I would sign them in for
agency yeah trade for them it's kind of
funny how that worked out right it did
backfire
not like haha funny but like ironically
funny yeah they are they're knocking on
the door they're too polite over here to
kick us out but they're they're peeking
in so that is our show Connor Mello and
I will be back Friday I will be jet lag
as a jet lagged person effort yeah it's
gonna be we got feedback about the curse
word so the kids in the car over here
yeah so we're trying to try not to as
much so yeah we will be jet LAG's but
it'll be fun
so Friday look for a new stick to
football thanks again to everyone at BR
London for letting us hang out in the
office and to the BR football ranks guys
for being awesome host this week